foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing a few new Harry Potter
potholes specifically from the
Philosopher's Stone before we begin
untangling the debut novel of our
beloved HP series however I just want to
highlight that this video is one in a
series of pothole videos that I've done
so if you haven't done so yet be sure to
watch my previous thoughts on Harry
Potter potholes in 10 huge Harry Potter
potholes ranked and 10 huge Harry Potter
plot holes part 2 ranked both of those
videos focus on overall potholes from
various installments throughout the
entire series but today of course we'll
focus entirely on the Philosopher's
Stone let's get into it number one the
whereabouts of Hagrid and Harry during
the missing day in the very beginning of
the novel we see Albus Dumbledore meet
Professor Minerva McGonagall on privet
drive as they await the arrival of
rubius hankrid who was entrusted with
bringing an infant Harry Potter to his
aunt and uncle's home this scene is
described as after dark as Dumbledore
uses his Pusher router to collect all of
the orbs of light from the surrounding
street lights to ensure they are not
seen by any neighbors we also know that
an entire day has passed since Voldemort
murdered Harry's parents and attempted
to murder him we know this because
Harry's Uncle Vernon dursley describes
all the odd things he sees that day on
his way to and during work these odd
things are of course the celebrations
The Wizarding World in response to
Voldemort's defeat this means that an
entire day has passed since the previous
evening when Hagrid took Harry from the
scene of the crime to the pair's arrival
at number four privet Drive leaving the
very obvious question of where the hell
were they for 24 hours now we know that
hankrid borrowed Sarah's Black's flying
motorbike but it clearly wouldn't have
taken a whole day to travel by magic
flying motorbike would it and we know he
flew the bike at least part of the way
because when he arrives his arrival was
from the air so with the math just not
adding up on this one it's definitely a
plot hole in my opinion 2. baby Harry
being left outside the dursleys are we
really meant to believe that the three
magical beings Dumbledore McGonagall and
Hagrid who claim to deeply care for the
Recently orphaned one-year-old Harry
just left him outside of the dursley's
doors in the middle of a chilly October
night think about it there's no mention
of any sort of magical spell cast to
protect tiny Harry from The Elements nor
do the three Wizards seem all that
bothered by the thought that they're
just dumping a baby on the Desi's
doorstep with the assumption that at
some point the next day either Vernon or
petunia will find him if not a plot hole
it is at the very least incredibly weird
number three Mrs Weasley not remembering
platform nine and three-quarters this
plot hole is more like a giant oversight
in my opinion readers of the
Philosopher's Stone may recall that the
only reason Harry notices the Weasley
family while at King's cross station is
that he overhears Ron's dear mum Molly
trying to remember the platform number
of the Hogwarts Express out loud I might
add I personally find it incredibly hard
to believe that after previously
bringing five Wheezy children to
platform nine and three quarters
throughout the course of their
educations at Hogwarts she would not
have this number absolutely cemented in
her mind not to mention that the
platform number never changes every
subsequent year that Harry catches the
train to school the platform is always
nine and three quarters number four the
concept of poor witches and wizards the
concept that members of The Wizarding
Community could be poor is a rather
confusing one if you ask me of course
we're clearly introduced to this idea in
the Philosopher's Stone with the
explanation of the Weasley's reputation
and description of Ron's shabby clothing
and hand-me-down wand but in a world in
which magic can conjure food and
transform one inanimate object into
another couldn't any witch or wizard who
want to do better off simply create more
wealth for themselves seems to me this
is quite a substantial plot hole number
five how the dersies returned from the
island as you will likely remember when
Harry started receiving his admission
letters to Hogwarts Vernon dursley
brought the entire family to a rickety
old Hut an isolated island in a
desperate attempt to hide from the
magical letters this didn't work of
course as Hagrid who was tasked to
ensure Harry did indeed receive his
acceptance letter easily tracked them
down and delivered Harry's mail to him
in person now the plot hole to this
portion of the story is that the island
was so isolated that the only way the
jerseys and Harry were able to get there
was to travel by a small rowboat as
Hagrid was granted permission from
Dumbledore to use magic until he found
Harry he himself flew over to the island
presumably using his umbrella which he
illegally constructed using his broken
wand but I digress anyway upon finding
Harry Hagrid was no longer authorized to
use magic so the two of them Departed
the island using the one and only
rowboat so how on Earth did the dursleys
get back to the mainland number 6. traps
for the stone were solved by untrained
children
now near the very beginning of the novel
the Philosopher's Stone is transferred
from Gringotts to Hogwarts by Hagrid on
the orders of Dumbledore presumably this
is done to keep the stone in the safest
place possible however white Dumbledore
believed that a castle filled with a
bunch of curious students would be a
more secure location than a magical bank
vault that trapped any trespasses for
eternity with goblins only checking the
Vault every decade or two is well beyond
me in any case we later learned that the
stone is placed behind traps and
enchantments created by all the combined
magical prowess that the professors of
Hogwarts had to offer which brings me to
a plot hole within this plot hole why
would the traps protecting this
incredibly valuable magical artifact be
solvable each trap is actually more of a
puzzle but once again I digress anyway
not only were each of the tramps
protecting the stone solvable they were
all solvable by a group of first-year
students not the best and brightest of
wizard kind but three eleven-year-olds
two of whom didn't even know magic
existed less than a year prior number
seven Hogwarts doesn't offer muggle core
subjects now it's arguable that perhaps
witches and wizards don't have much use
for maths or muggle history but the fact
that there's no language classes is a
bit baffling to me firstly you'd think
there'd be even a minor focus on being
able to properly write and communicate
but also I would have thought the
language of other countries not to
mention other magical species would have
been offered as at least electives 8.
the required school suppliers are
archaic okay this has never made any
sense to me I mean I get that magic is
often associated with medieval times and
whatnots but why on Earth would one of
the most prominent Wizarding schools in
the world have not evolved with modern
times in terms of school supplies I mean
perhaps with some witches and wizards
living over a century a few of these
items May simply have not been phased
out yet as in I could see some of the
older professors not updating the list
of what's required for their classes but
you'd think that the teenagers who make
up the majority of Hogwarts population
would have at the very least requested
the option of getting a pack of pens in
a notebook instead of quills and
parchment 9. the hypocritical punishment
for breaking curfew as you may recall
partway through the Philosopher's Stone
Harry is caught breaking curfew a curfew
which has been instated to protect the
students of Hogwarts and yet and yet the
very punishment bestowed upon the
children for being out after dark is to
send them out into the dark and not just
any dark but dark within the Forbidden
Forest full of creepy and dangerous
magical creatures I'm so bizarre 10.
Dumbledore destroying the stone in the
end
though when Dumbledore explains to Harry
at the very end of the novel that the
stone has simply been destroyed a very
obvious question cramped wait no lumped
into my mind why go to all that trouble
to protect the stone transfer it from
Gringotts to Hogwarts only to end up
destroying it if getting rid of it was
the safest option shouldn't that have
been the first option I mean I'm all for
trying something out to see if it works
but this seems like an incredibly risky
thing to have done I suppose there is
the argument that Alba suspected that
Voldemort was gaining strength and
thought this might be a good way to gas
him out or something or perhaps he
simply wanted to see what Harry Potter
was capable of since he admits in the
final installment of the series that
he's been mentoring him in order to meet
his death against Voldemort or maybe
this is just another plot hole with no
rational explanation and with that we've
come to the end of another video what do
you think did I miss any super super
obvious plot holes that have always
bothered you in the Philosopher's Stone
or perhaps you don't agree with one
maybe two please share your objections
further explanations and theories in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]